how are you Clark I'm the perfect how
are you this morning I'm doing great how
do you see tonight's matchup I know you
know what it's interesting Villanova
clearly deserves to be the favorite
they've been as impressive as any team
in recent tournament memory the way
they've shot it that they've defended at
a better level but you go back and
sometimes these overwhelming or large
favorites in a one game situation run
into a team that plays good enough to
beat them and Michigan has that capacity
and capability they defend at a good
level they've got a very versatile and
mobile and skilled big guy Moe vogner
the key is going to be can Michigan
defend but more importantly can they
score well enough from multiple
positions to keep up with that high
octane offensive Villanova and I think
it's doable
but it's gonna take a lot of pieces
moving well together to make it happen
what makes Villanova so great do you
think Clark well they can put five guys
on the floor rich they can all shoot it
legitimately seven of their guys shoot
between 35 and 45 percent from the
three-point line and two of those guys
are big guys Pascal and Spelman and it
really puts teams in the dilemma because
very rarely do you have one big guy
mobile enough to defend on the perimeter
let alone two and those guys are
legitimate shot makers from the three
play bigger than they are they're not
that tall Pascal and Spelman but they're
long they're physical they're strong and
they're bouncy and so they can play
bigger than they are and they shoot it
like small guy there Pascal with 24
points on 10 yeah of 11 shooting beyond
his nor
worst of the three points range okay so
and Spellman is up over 40 legitimately
I mean and this is not a small sample
size this guy has made a big number a
huge number of threes and you know
people talk about they made 18 of them
they averaged 11 makes a game on the
year 40% as a team so while that was
above the norm it's not that far off
from what they typically do they've had
a handful of games where they've been
the Texas Tech game a case in point
where they've been sub 30% shooting
threes but by and large they're shooting
between 40 and 55 percent from that
3-point line 80 percent of the time CBS
Sports Clark Kellogg Iran the Rich Eisen
show on the national championship Monday
would you say that the way Villanova is
playing we just mentioned its margin of
victory for the month of March was just
shy of 19 a game that you mentioned at
the very minimum they've got four shoot
guys on the floor we can shoot if not
all five that that Jay Wright and the
Villanova Wildcats are changing the way
that college basketball is going to be
played from here on out well we see a
shift the three-point line is a huge
part of the game and it's become even
larger and that's not changing or it's
just like technology it's not going away
it's just going to continue to expand
and evolve and find greater uses and the
same with the three-point shot you're
gonna recruit to spacing the floor and
the more good shooters you can have out
there the more space you have to get
three-point shots but also the drive to
get offensive rebounds when you miss
your case your three-point shots are dry
so clearly the spacing of the floor
through the three-point shot is a huge
part of basketball not just College
certainly the pros have embraced it
analytics plays a part in that in terms
of the value and efficiency of a three
and the layup two versus long contested
two-point shot so they're not changed
and if the game is changing and they're
actually enjoying the ride of the change
and executing that change at a really
high level so John Beilein
the job that he has done with this team
Clark I've said that he's the best coach
in Michigan basketball history and I
know I'm talking you know we're
involving Johnny or and then the run
that Steve Fisher went on with six
straight wins on that night in Seattle
that hope hopefully for Michigan's sake
they get to repeat cut down the nets
tonight I mean what this guy does is
remarkable what do you think he can do
this evening
Oh's wise to pull off what everybody
believes will be a major upset one of
the things Xiao Wei and he's clearly one
of the best coaches in our game has been
for a long time rich wherever he's been
he's maxed out his teams he's been
innovative he's been detailed he's been
effective and successful he's one of my
favorite coaches and all the college
basketball not just because I like
coaches but how he goes about a business
how he conducts himself as a man I just
have a lot of admiration and respect for
who he is and what he does ex and all
wise you've got it really I think
control the ball and be disciplined and
not going for pump fakes ball fakes
staying in the gaps not over helping
that's a lot that's a table full of
stuff that you got to do but they
they're capable of doing it and they'll
be locked in and able to do it to me the
key is gonna be offensively how
efficient can you be in maintaining pace
with the way Villanova can score that to
me is gonna be the key element in the
game and that's gonna require more than
mo vogner other guys abdur-rahman
Charles Matthews has been terrific for
the last seven weeks he's got to
continue to play at that level but you
need all hands on deck offensively
against Villanova I think and that and
and because Michigan has that capacity I
think they've got a chance to surprised
a lot of folks on them tonight and in
terms of the final four coverage on
Saturday Clark vogner coming over the
bench breaking rafter ease lenses and
then Grant Hill looking like you know
the Mack truck
preferably he was heading his way what's
what's the one moment of your
broadcasting career that you felt
physically threatened by whatever was
come on I can't even recall one rich and
that unique set up with being with the
Floor Elevators right creates an
opportunity for what we saw Grant looked
to me like one of those pictures you
take after being on an amusement-park
rollercoaster yes you know when you come
back and you look to see what kind of
faces everybody was making and he looked
like he was on some type of big-time
rollercoaster going down that big first
but I'm not I can't recall based on
where I've been positioned whether
they're doing pacer games back in the
day or what I've done with CBS I can't
recall them in the basketball may be
headed that way but nobody has come that
close to me now let me ask you Clark I
mean if somebody like yourself who has
played the game at a high level and has
broadcast at a high level
do you give grant a little grief for
having that rare no no no no no I
wouldn't know many of my colleagues and
others would but I'm just not that way I
mean it was a natural spontaneous look
of fear I mean so Charles is not rubbed
off on you is that what you're saying
well I mean that's one way to look at it
I guess now then I'll take a jab but not
in that circumstance I think that was
one where anybody would have had an
expression on their face I don't care
cuz you can't prepare for that I mean
how how can you control what your face
is gonna contort into when you gotta 611
250 pound guy about the fly in all of
Germany coming your way you know and
plus he just got into the Naismith Hall
of Fame like I finally get in the Hall
when it's going to end this way before I
let you go in that San Antonio afternoon
and night Clark what do you think
happens tonight man I tell you so many
folks are not you know I'm leaning
Villanova's way because they just
haven't shown any real weaknesses and
their championship caliber they've got a
couple of guys that have been in this
setting but the upset potential is
greater than people think it's going to
take a yeoman's effort I'm still
debating as to what actually I'm going
to say when Ernie throws it to me with
who you got I'm still contemplating I
think it's gonna be an entertaining game
I'm hopeful that Michigan rises to the
level offensively because if they do it
could be as entertaining I guess is
maybe the 13 championship game when
Louisville and Michigan played and what
I thought was one of the more
entertaining and competitive
championship games we have pace of play
was good shot making was really good and
it was highly entertaining pretty much
from start to finish except for the
finish for some
where you were rooting and what colors
you wear but in terms of an objective
basketball fan that was I was really fun
to watch
Clark look forward to it thanks for the
call appreciate it that's Clark Kellogg
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience